but I remember you're special from the
prison yeah nobody got mad at you in the
prison oh that was different that was a
little different that's a little
different there might have been one or
two
but I think in the end but it doesn't
matter they're locked up they can't no
they're all that's the other thing about
it I shot that eight years ago so
they're out
they start coming out everybody's a
murderer some people are just in there
for a little while so there was a guy
and God I might regret telling the story
one day when he shows up but there was a
guy if you recall early in the show he
had swastika tattoos and I made some
joke we're probably cutting in a clip of
that right now if you're watching it on
YouTube and you know you've got a good
crowd we have a clip here let's take a
look
the white dudes hang out
does anybody ever get offended by your
tattoo sometimes anyway good luck with
the rest of your stay in jail how many
years 99 dude you should get six million
years for every Jew that died in the
Holocaust
man
that looks against you
and I said something to the effect of
the wall the war is over but that tattoo
is permanent and and you know everyone
laughed at him he was he was a little he
was embarrassed and I did a couple other
lines about him and I moved on and it
became a sort of a you know a viral
moment and people mentioned it to me in
the press and I think Conan showed a
clip and so uh last year I did get a DM
from the guy because I recognized his
face going I'm out [__] LOL
oh my God explain to me where the LOL
comes in I guess it's his way of not
he's going back to jail if he didn't put
the LOL I could have reported him but he
probably would have broken his his
parole but uh and then there's another
thing did you did you answer him no no I
was scared okay I was scared this is the
answer right now telling this story his
name is Kenny his name is Kenny and now
he does our commercials and he has a dog
Kenny out of this Texas Nazi listening
to Howie and Jackie's podcast is
probably probably slim but there is
another thing going on with that show
and I haven't talked about this at all
but it came up right before New Year's
where uh
the I'm involved in a death penalty
case what stems from that show tell me
um
I went a week early this is Texas where
they take their law enforcement very
seriously seriously as I take my comedy
and you know I had written a thousand
jails and finally got one to let me come
in this is a special on Comedy Central
called Jeff Ross roast criminals and I'm
there a week so I get to know everybody
because I wanted a method roast like
know everybody before the show it's like
come in on Monday I'm eating breakfast
I'm playing basketball I'm eating lunch
I'm interviewing people with the
convicts with the in the people that are
in incarcerated and I learned that too
you know over the course of it I don't
call them prisoners I don't call them
convicts they're people that are in jail
I wanted to humanize them I wanted to
sort of understand them I didn't want to
prejudge and most importantly I didn't
want to know what their crime was if
they wanted to tell me they could tell
me so I don't know a murderer from a guy
who didn't pay his his parking tickets
and
I walk into this one room you know it's
full of full of dudes probably 50 dudes
in there I don't know what their crimes
are but there's this table off to off in
the back with two or three really scary
gigantic white supremacists and sitting
between them almost like holding Court
is a 19 year old Asian kid
so the whole prison is white
supremacists and like Mexican gang
bangers were teardrop tattoos and then
this little scrawny kid and it wasn't my
best moment Howie you know comic the
comic I I was like what are you in for
hacking a computer and you know the guys
laugh and this kid goes oh I hacked some
hacking's the operative word
and I was like huh oh no I talked to him
a couple more minutes it didn't really
go anywhere and
uh the next day you know or shortly
after that footage all gets subpoenaed
into this kid's I don't know why or
what's going on turns out he hacked up a
college professor
um in Texas
at Texas A M
um
killed him killed him and wanted to see
him die he admitted it
and he badly wounded the guy's wife who
was in a wheelchair he was ruthless
and the when he was sentenced they used
the footage of him making that joke with
me
to show that he was unremmorsful and
gave him the death penalty
so
his lawyers are
um
what's the word subpoena no uh uh
appealing his death penalty convention
to conviction to the Supreme Court
so now I'm waiting to find out if the
Supreme Court's going to help this guy
do you
have an opinion on the death penalty I
do
so are you upset that you're depending
what's your opinion do you want to say
it's a mixed message because this guy is
what the death penalty is designed you
know what I'm gonna hold I'm gonna hold
off because I don't want to further
influence what happens
I'm not pro death penalty I'm gonna bite
my tongue on this one but I will say
it's very unlikely
the Supreme Court will the good the bad
news is the Supreme Court probably won't
help this guy the good news is I'm
performing at their Christmas party this
December so
that's my way out of it yeah
[Music]